TELLE WHITNEY: It is such
a pleasure and an honor
to be here today.
I'm very committed
to technology.
I'm very committed to being
a woman in technology.
How many of you are?
Look around the room.
There are so many people
that you can connect with.
And connection is an important
part of, certainly, my story.
This last week, I
had the pleasure
to meet with Melissa
Pierce, who's doing
a documentary on Grace Hopper.
How many people know
who Grace Hopper is?
Oh, good.
Well, you should know more
once the documentary comes out.
Well, she and I were
talking about how important
it was in our lives to find
other women to connect with.
I'm going to tell you
a couple of stories
about my own journey,
but also talk
about how to pay it forward.
Everything that I do, I find
a way to work with others.
That really, ultimately,
is what it's about.
At heart of my story
is taking risks.
The picture you
see on the screen,
I was at the base camp of Mt.
Everest.
[APPLAUSE]
Something I had
always wanted to do.
I was a technologist.
I'm a computer
scientist by background,
and I worked in the
semiconductor field.
And I built chips.
That's what I did, and
a lot of my self-worth
and self-awareness
was as a technologist.
But there were not
very many women,
and so I made a point of finding
women who I could talk to,
even if they weren't in my job.
And that's how I met Anita Borg.
Anita and I founded the
Grace Hopper Celebration.
Anita founded the Institute
for Women in Technology.
She was then two years later
diagnosed with brain cancer.
She had a great
board-- Maria Klawe,
who's the president
of Harvey Mudd
and who was the founding chair.
Bill Wolfe, who is the head
of the National Academy.
But she needed help.
But I was a technologist.
So I was willing to help
her, but not step in.
They did a search
for a president,
but the financials--
they couldn't
attract the right people.
So rather reluctantly, I
stepped in as interim president
in 2002 of June.
And I have stayed.
So not only did I take the risk
of going to an organization
that needed my help, I
took at will a left turn.
I think that often, careers
are about seeing opportunities
and going for it.
I have the best job on
the face of the planet.
You know, nowadays I do
work with lots of people
who are starting non-profits.
This last week I met with two
young men who are starting
a 501(c)(3) to have computer
coding camps at local
universities.
When people reach
out, I make the time.
Just like when I needed
it and I reached out,
other people made the time.
But I do often think that
we don't take enough risks.
How many people can
remember that time
when there was something
that you really wanted to do,
and you decided not to do it?
Finding a way to
take that plunge--
I will encourage all of you.
And as part of taking risks, you
want to ask for what you want.
There's a great book
called Women Don't Ask.
I would encourage each and
every one of you to read it.
If you look at that negotiation
of that first salary-- I mean,
men do it.
Women don't.
If any of you heard
Satya Nadella's comments
at Grace Hopper, you know
that you have the backlash.
You know that women need to ask.
You can see that
in this picture.
This is Alan Eustace,
who's on our board, who's
at Google, with all these
people around him asking him
for help and advice.
When I went to
Malleable Technology--
we built a voiceover
IP processor--
they gave me a good salary,
and they gave me stock.
The CEO was somebody I knew.
And once again, I
was taking a risk.
I was employee number four.
We had enough money in
the bank for six months.
We built that organization.
We sold it 18 months
later to PMC-Sierra.
And I hired the vast majority
of the people in the company.
So imagine my shock when we were
sold and the amount of shares
became public that my peer
on the executive team-- there
was three of us-- had
significantly more stock
than I did.
I was hurt.
I was ashamed.
And I was so angry.
[LAUGHTER]
And so I went to my boss,
this person who I was sure
was going to take care of me.
He knew what kind of
contributions I was making.
He knew how significant
my contribution--
and the entire part of
developing the company was.
I ask him, why?
Tell me.
And he said, you didn't ask.
Since that day, I
really make it a point
to understand what I
want and to really decide
what it is that I'm asking.
But perhaps more
important-- and this
gets back to the
fundamental belief
that you have to
pay it forward--
I talk to others about it.
One of our two
student board members
is a young woman
from Southwestern,
and she's now graduating
and looking for a job.
And she and I were
talking about the fact
of how important it was to reach
out and ask for what you want.
It's just one of those things
that I take home every day.
And then the last point
I'll make about taking
risks is to ask for help.
On the screen,
you see the people
who are the most
important to me--
my most important connections.
On the left is my PhD
thesis adviser, Carver Mead.
He was the ultimate sponsor
for the first many years
of my career.
He introduced me to people
who were starting companies.
He supported me in my work.
On the top, you see my good
friend, Valerie Taylor,
the Executive Director of
the Center for Minorities
and People with
Disabilities in IT.
I go to her for advice all the
time, and I sit on her board
and I help her understand
how to create a nonprofit.
This is all new for her.
Maria Kalwe, who's on
the stage with myself
and Sheryl Sandberg, is the
ultimate close personal friend.
Very much a mentor.
Maria has always
been there for me,
but she always
tells me how it is.
She gives me the hard truth when
I don't really want to hear it.
And then both Sheryl
Sandberg and Megan Smith
are supportive of
the work that we
do at the Anita Borg Institute.
They are in my larger
network, and they make a point
to really support our work.
Who's in your network?
And I talked a lot about how
these are the people that
allowed me to thrive.
If you think about it,
the next generation,
who are the people who
allow them to thrive?
I make it a point to meet
with anybody who wants to.
I told you about
Natalia Rodriguez,
who's a young student.
But those times where people are
making an important transition
and they reach out to have a
conversation today-- actually,
I had an event earlier today and
a young is starting a company
and she says, can we talk?
And I said yes.
So think about how you can
reach out to those around you
and help them.
Yes, you need to
get your own help.
Yes, you need to have the best
career you can possibly have.
But what can you
do to help others?
The network-- I mean,
look around the room.
These are connections.
These are possible
peer mentors, everyone
of the people in this room.
Find out what they're doing.
Find out how you can learn
from every one of them.
Think about your job.
Who are the young engineers?
And I would say, this
is both men and women
who you can share
your experience with.
Think about your
local high schools.
Many of the technical
people I know volunteer
at their local high schools.
They talk about their job.
There are so many
young kids that
just don't even know
what we do, don't even
know if it's a possibility.
In the same way that I
needed help in order for me
to be successful, I
want to give back.
One of the greatest experiences
that I have in my life
is at the Grace
Hopper Celebration.
One of those great joys
is a walk around the room,
and these young women
come up to me and say,
this conference changed my life.
To see for so many young women
who are working in an area
where they're just
one of very few women,
the chance to have a
conversation with somebody
who's just a few years older
than them, to understand
what's possible.
When people ask you
for help, give back.
Pay it forward.
The other thing along the
topic of asking for help
is that for you
to be successful,
people need to know what you do.
It's not what you know,
it's not who you know,
but it is who knows
what you know.
And as you think
about asking for help,
think about what the
people in your organization
or other organizations
can do to advise you
about how to get ahead.
So I know that you're going
to have a wonderful day.
I hope that you
remember to take risks,
to ask for what you want,
and to ask for help.
We want you to be at the table
creating the technology that
will change all of our
lives, and each one of you
can help make that so.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]